[Aplausos]
según el último informe del inegi
y el último reporte de hábitos de los
internautas de la asociación mexicana de
internet amipci casi 75 millones de
mexicanos son internautas
de los cuales el rango de edad de 6 a 17
años constituyen el 26 por ciento de
todos
y todos ellos
están en riesgo de caer en redes de
tratantes de personas
para fines de esclavitud moderna o de
fines de explotación sexual
ahora es un poquito para atrás
la verdad es que internet es una
maravilla
conectividad worldwide a todo el mundo y
en tiempo real podemos ver avances desde
nuestros smartphones podemos ver en
realidad aumentada
en realidad virtual coches de conducción
autónoma
y por supuesto la inteligencia
artificial
podemos usarla para muchísimas cosas
para academia para superación personal
para networks socializar
podemos usarla para muchísimas cosas que
construyan en el mundo
desafortunadamente les tengo una noticia
así como vemos mucha gente buena también
hay mucha gente mala
imagínense que todo lo que les acabo de
decir caiga en manos erróneas
que se pueden imaginar
desde coches que se manejan solos mal
manejados
una brecha de datos
algo por el estilo
les voy a compartir algo que le pasó a
mi mejor amiga regina
pero mucho como menos de seis meses le
clonaron su identidad su plantaron su
identidad por medio de capturas de
pantalla
bajaron sus fotos e hicieron otro perfil
la verdad es que solo lo hicieron con la
intención de molestar se metieron con
sus amigos con nosotros
literalmente buscaban hacerle un daño a
lo mejor no patrimonial a lo mejor
solamente a sus amistades solo la
envidia pudiera ser
no lo sabemos
sin embargo la madurez de regina
pudo pudo suceder
y realizar que lo dejara de lado
sin embargo la ineficacia de instagram y
sus procesos no han cerrado la cuenta el
día de hoy
y ahí sigue un fake
algo que no hizo tanto daño
profundicemos un poquito
un poquito nada más esto fue un tema
social un tema personal
qué pasaría
si nos vamos a un tema que induzca el
suicidio porque así lo hubo en como una
persona de otra nacionalidad que creó un
juego juego en internet el que llevó al
suicidio a muchos niños
la ballena azul
y como eso hay muchísimos ejemplos
suplantación de identidad o usurpación
de identidad
eso ahorita se está volviendo muy común
marc goodman habla de twitter crimes o
de los crímenes del futuro eso es el día
de hoy
eso no tenemos que irnos unos años
adelante eso es nuestra realidad
esos son los crímenes de hoy
le endeudar a una persona por medio de
robar su identidad
buscar y acosar personas hoy en día está
muy de moda
desgraciadamente acosar personas
prioritariamente mujeres
pero saben que también está de moda y no
lo vemos la trata de personas
la trata de personas se hace por
internet pero antes que es trata de
personas
trata de personas es captar
trasladar
a o recibir personas con fines de
explotación ya sea esclavitud ya sea con
fines de explotación sexual ya sea con
fines de explotación laboral un
matrimonio forzoso o forzado
hay muchísimas formas miles de formas de
explotación
y eso se vive los tratantes de personas
usan el internet
hay un libro muy ilustrativo del mabel
lozano que se llama el proxeneta en el
cual ilustra como miguel el músico
literalmente se dedicaba a esto a
delinquir a tratar personas a traer
mujeres desde un continente a otro
corrompiendo funcionarios públicos
y logrando incidir negativamente en la
vida de personas que las tenían en
condiciones precarias
mujeres que vivían de alomejor 10
personas en un cuarto
sin una comida saludable
sin una higiene
y como pudiéramos pensar en la trata de
personas por internet que está diciendo
este tipo
muy sencillo 1 en la fase de captación
normalmente ellos recurren al engaño
recurren a ofrecer trabajos
prioritariamente si es de niños o niñas
oye tú puedes ser modelo pobres
pero esto no se trata nada más de
describirles
la trata de personas y que es un tema
real se trata este télex de desafiar el
futuro y como lo vamos a desafiar
previniendo dándonos cuenta en principio
sabiendo que nuestra información vale
hay mucha gente que me ha dicho ahorita
contemporáneamente oye luisa ver la
verdad es que yo soy medio
intrascendente la información que subo
en mis redes sociales no vale para nada
no tengo nada que esconder
entonces yo no soy valioso alguna vez
hice la broma de a lo mejor para tu
cross honor es valioso
pero la verdad es que para algunas
empresas eres estadística que la
información es poder tú dime si no es
valioso eso pero por otro lado
tenemos a los criminales si te vuelves
un target te vuelves un blanco
un blanco de cualquier delito
suplantación de identidad o usurpación
robo secuestro trata
cualquiera
hay que entender y hay que saber que la
privacidad puede salvar vidas
hoy me espero que es privacidad a todo
esto
pues les voy a compartir
como tal una definición muy precisa de
la privacidad
se han peleado muchos doctrinarios en
darla
desde todos los continentes continentes
americanos todos
distintos idiomas distintos países eeuu
la unión europea-méxico pero todos
coinciden en algo tu información
tu privacidad tiene que ver con lo que
tú haces público o expones a los demás y
lo que no qué fácil se escucha eso el
derecho a estar solo a gozar de una vida
íntima
cuántas veces lo hemos pensado realmente
que es íntimo y que no
se han puesto a pensarlo
a fin de cuentas según peters wire en el
libro del sector privado de de
privacidad en eeuu de la internación
asociación los propios y profesionales
ubican cuatro tipos de privacidad o
rubros en los que podemos encajar
corporal territorial en las
comunicaciones y en la información
yo no entiendo cómo es que muchas veces
vemos a alguien que no nos da buena
pinta cerramos la puerta con seguro y
con 20 llaves
cerramos nuestras ventanas ojalá
nuestras persianas y es más en las
comunicaciones qué tal cuando estamos
escribiendo
y de repente el de al lado empiezan
lo que hacemos esto que te importa
brother
porque no lo hacemos con nuestra vida en
las redes sociales
en la información que damos a las
dependencias gubernamentales a las
empresas porque todo todo en fuera de
nuestra casa es un libro abierto
está mal el internet y las redes
sociales son una cosa del demonio no
mejor como dije desde el principio es
una herramienta persona herramienta que
debemos saber usar
y así como entender que la privacidad en
un consenso general es decidir qué hago
público y que no también debo de valorar
qué con qué consecuencias me va a traer
a ello
es muy importante
por ello este día en este télex con
todos mis compañeros y todos los
presentes ponemos un granito de arena
para salvar vidas louis cómo podemos
salvar vidas
muy sencillo
con cinco pasos que he identificado y
que les comparto
y el primero es valorar nuestra
privacidad
porque no la valoramos no conocemos y
cómo podemos valorar algo que no
conocemos sana como ilógico no sé cómo
le voy a dar valor algo que
ni siquiera me pasa por la cabeza
entonces los invito a informarse más a
profundizar ya que conocemos
que es nuestra privacidad que alcances
tiene que profundidad entonces vamos al
interés de nuestra vida cotidiana
si tenemos hijos tenemos sobrinos nietos
etcétera
debemos entender que la privacidad no
solo de nosotros tenemos que fomentar
este derecho porque es un derecho humano
a fin de cuentas lo tenemos en la
constitución lo tenemos en las leyes y
la verdad es que está reconocido a nivel
internacional
así que después de conocer el derecho
después de conocer qué valor tiene
después de profundizar los invito a que
deliberen
qué medidas de seguridad que les
acomodan para su vida cotidiana porque a
ver es una cadena lógica ya que conozco
me interesó ya que me interesó
profundizó ya que profundizó veo que me
acomoda y qué no
y qué crees que siga
pues llevarlo a la acción no porque de
nada sirve por ejemplo en el círculo
rojo que yo intenté
lo estoy intentando estudiantes
intentando pisar el círculo rojo
y la diferencia es que no lo intente ya
lo pisé eso debemos hacer con esta
privacidad
a diario
y por último
y difundir este mensaje y salvar vidas
como salvó vidas
literalmente informando concientizando
profundizando y transmitiendo este
conocimiento a quienes no solo los que
estamos aquí en este foro o a los que
tenemos de audiencia
sino ir involucrarnos a zonas marginadas
a zonas de que el internet no tiene un
acceso tan fácil
y no lo digo por el alcance del internet
luego por las posibilidades de los
habitantes en tal región
es invitarlos es involucrarnos en este
problema actual
qué vamos a lograr a lo mejor salvamos
una vida
a lo mejor salvamos a que quien en este
momento en el ted talks el télex de luís
hernández está siendo captado por un
tratante de personas oa quien está
siendo explotado o explotada por que
proyectaremos mujeres
en un prostíbulo
porque se escucha muy fuerte pero quién
va a hablar de esto si no si no somos
nosotros
quien va a ser un cambio ella ni se diga
de todos aquellos que lo consumen porque
eso sí irrita
todos aquellos que consumen los
servicios derivados de la trata cuáles
son algunos la prostitución la
prostitución forzada cómo se van a dar
cuenta quién es forzada y quién no si se
deja de consumir entonces ya no se trata
el consumidor es parte muy importante o
que me dicen de la pornografía y la
pornografía infantil
y si no queremos irnos tan lejos en la
trata de personas que me dicen de las
venganzas de verne rebensburg
que está tan de moda ahorita está tan en
boga personas literalmente abusando de
la confianza de gente que hizo sexting
que es literalmente en mandar
fotos desnudos y cuando cortan los
novios van y difunden todo este tipo de
cosas buenas malas personas no las
buenas las buenas no lo hacen
entonces realmente estamos tan lejos de
esto
no nuestra prima nuestra hermana nuestra
sobrina nuestra hija nuestra alguien lo
puede estar sufriendo y ahorita puede
estar amenazado y ahorita nosotros
estamos generando este cambio pero en el
ínter alguien puede estar extorsionado
extorsionada
y saben que es lo peor
que por esto muy probablemente ahorita
va a callar
y mañana va a estar muerta
por eso hay tanta gente desaparecida
principalmente porque no prevenimos
porque ya qué
ya que suceden los problemas es que los
atendemos
y cuando nos hemos puesto a pensar que
vamos a prevenir algo porque no me puede
pasar como me va a pasar a mí
hay abogados que nos han defraudado
en doctores que han muerto de alguna
enfermedad previsible
y así puedo encontrar un ejemplo para
todos nosotros
para todos nosotros algo que me
encantaría en este granito de arena es
invitarlos a que prevengan y sobre todo
valoren su privacidad
porque son ustedes mismos es su
información es nuestra información
qué va a pasar el día de hoy
sigue que en una cuenta
una bridge
literalmente nos vamos a quedar
expuestos justo como el 26 por ciento de
los internautas que mencioné al
principio expuestos
y así estamos todos
no está mal usar las redes sociales no
están mal usar el internet oye lo quiero
para prospección comercial y make est
adelante
pero comencemos a
y un paso atrás
tener todo el ambiente tener la visión
panorámica
de lo que puede generar una simple foto
de lo que puede generar a quien le digo
qué cosa porque los secretos los
cuidamos
o no
cuidamos a quien se lo decimos pero qué
tal la foto sin playera del joven que
acaba de ir al gym él acaba de postear
está bien qué tal que el día de mañana
esa persona sufre un accidente o sufre
una venganza de alguien más es muy
complicado
por eso
finalizó invitándolos
a que por medio de la privacidad
salvemos vidas muchas gracias yo soy
luis hernández
[Aplausos]